welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this episode
were breaking down the new season of
narcos Mexico throughout the video we're
going to be giving our thoughts on the
latest entry and discussing the
real-life events that inspired it there
will be heavy spoilers here so if you
haven't had a chance to check out the
season yet and don't want to know what
happens then I highly suggest that you
turn off now without the way I just want
to give a huge thank you for clicking
the video now let's get into our
breakdown of narcos Mexico season 2
season 1 followed agent of the DEA Kiki
played by Michael Pena hot on the tail
of drug trafficker Felix we watched as
they played a game of cat-and-mouse that
came to a sticky end
Kiki was tortured and killed by Felix
and in order to combat the war on drugs
the u.s. sent in its own agents to
infiltrate the cartels within the
country season 2 of narcos Mexico is
very much about the retribution for
Kiki's death
Felix crossed the line in killing the
agent and nurse escalation and shoes
within the US government having to also
step over the boundaries in order to
keep up with the Rays stakes
knockos up until this point has very
much been a case of the cartels being in
control and the DEA trying to play
catch-up with them however where season
2 differs is that it switches up the
dynamics and actually has the US forces
making the first move and driving the
charge in comparison to the other
previous protagonists Walt feels like he
moves in shades of grey in the past
everything was by the book but after the
cartel themselves broke the rules things
have changed
they passed suspects across the border
carry out insane carjacks torture
suspects and use guerrilla tactics to
attain their targets this newfound power
doesn't necessarily make things easier
though and quickly they realize they
don't have the cartel the cartel has
them early on the season has one of the
most brutal scenes in the series so far
and it mirrors Kiki's fate at the end of
the first there's a great theme through
the season that in fighting monsters you
should avoid becoming one and you start
to wonder who is really the bad guy in
all of this after the Mexican earthquake
in 1985 the country is in the midst of a
political shake-up the presidential
campaign that arises from this plays a
big part in the show and this puts many
people most notably felix in a
vulnerable position
seizures are up the DEA has doubled its
number and as we know from the real-life
story felix is living on borrowed time
where the ending of the prior season
made us think that he may end up being
more cautious it's actually quite the
opposite he still throws lavish parties
gets given tigers as gifts and all of
this attracts further attention it pays
to have friends and his actions force
him to reach out to other big names such
as Don Horn however quickly he realizes
that not many wish to be his ally due to
the war that he has created this draws
heavily from the real-life story of
felix and as usual the show perfectly
recaptures history in real life after
the special unit identified felix as the
perpetrator of Kiki's murder they slowly
began to uncover all of the corrupt
officials involved as well this kicked
off a search for him but he maintained
political protection for a large part of
the late 80s people refused to testify
against him took the blame and more but
he painted himself into a corner felix
was one whose reach always exceeded his
grasp and this ambition was ultimately
his downfall the real-life figure was
born in bellavista on a lowly ranch and
this rise from peasant to kingpin
probably made him believe he was
invincible felix was initially a Mexican
federal judicial police agent that
worked as a bodyguard for a state
politician but as we know he eventually
got into narcotics trafficking and took
control of several routes we also see
Isabella Bautista on a similar path to
Felix wishing to cut off many in order
to get her own roots though a fictional
character isabella is actually based
heavily on Sandra Beltran Beltran was
the daughter of Maria Felix and Alfonso
Quintero
former cartel owners her family
connections helped her become the so
called queen of the drug trade and
officials say that she was the niece of
Felix but this was often disputed
she reportedly had several affairs with
well-known drug barons and both of her
husband's were ex police commanders both
were killed by assassins and she rose
through the ranks until her high-profile
arrests in 2007 Beltran operated for
decades without giving the police
anything they could pin on her but after
a son was kidnapped and had a five
million dollar ransom slapped on his
head she contacted the authorities this
gave them an in and they took a closer
look at Beltran and arrested her not
long after though she described herself
in police interviews as a housewife who
earned money selling clothes she was
convicted of laundering billions of
dollars
Beltran spent seven years in jail but
after charges were dropped she was
allowed to walk free
another big female character in the
season is Mimi Webb Miller who becomes
involved in the cartel life through a
boyfriend Pablo Acosta
Mimi actually avoided persecution
possibly due to her relationship with
former presidents and the fact her uncle
was a senator Pablo was a botched for
her saying that she didn't have anything
to do with it even though the show does
say that she was aware of what was going
on it's ambiguous over whether Mimi was
involved or not so I don't want to say
she had anything to do with it as the
show could bend the truth or it may not
and at this point the only thing we know
is that she was never charged for any of
the events depicted in the season when
Pablo was killed
Mimi left the life behind and currently
she runs tours along the border of
Mexico and the United States and finally
another notable character that comes
into his own in this season is El Chapo
chapo pretty much has a reputation right
now that puts him up there in statue
with Escobar he is considered to be one
of the most powerful traffickers of all
time he entered the narcotics trade
through his father and created several
roots to move his boss hector salazar's
product he ended up supervising
logistics for felix and after Galanos
arrest formed his own cartel chapo had
his hand in everything and due to the
tunnels he built under the border he was
able to export more than any other
figure in history Forbes even ranked him
as one of the most powerful people in
the world from 2009 to 2013 chapo was
first captured in 1993 where he was
extradited and sentenced to 20 years
however after bribing guards at the
maximum
security prison-- he managed to escape
in 2001 he became a fugitive with an 8
million-dollar bounty on his head and
was finally arrested in 2014 he once
more escaped through a tunnel in his
cell before he was recaptured in 2016
Chapo had Gira's killed bribed officials
and was one of the most influential
figures in the narcotics business for a
long time
finally in 2019 he was caught and found
guilty of a vast amount of criminal
charges he is currently serving a life
sentence in ADX Florence but whether he
stays there remains to be seen
all in all there are a number of notable
characters and personally if I had to
ding the series I would say that it
feels overstuffed whereas the original
centered around Pablo Escobar this pulls
a lot more in and some of the plot
threads seem to drag slightly as it's
difficult to get attached to any
character when we spend so much time
with them the season clocking in at 10
hours definitely feels a lot slower than
the others and these elements of it made
it slightly less engaging for me than
the prior entries in the beginning
there's a lot of repetition throughout
with people sitting around talking about
deals rather than there being a tense
feeling to what's going on the season
finally gets it through us to it when
Felix becomes involved in the political
part either PRI he rigs an election and
shows he is elevated in terms of what
he's willing to do this is where
everything gets interesting I just wish
it didn't take so long to get to this
point the voter suppression and the
broadcasting of big results is genius
and actually reflects our own times and
the world of fake news that we live in
this makes the show extremely relevant
to today's current climate and shows how
easily the public can be manipulated
those around him begin to turn against
him and Walt meets with Mimi who takes
him to Pablo where they discuss Felix's
organization and the couple decide to
get out it's revealed that Mimi is
pregnant and it's clear that she's
changed Pablo's perception of the world
he rats out Felix and gives up the names
of those involved in the operation to a
newspaper after realizing that sooner or
later they will kill him he isolates
himself and surrounds himself with
protection but this doesn't guarantee
safety in an FBI raid that they storm is
complex and it's one of the most in
hence action scenes in the show's
history Walt goes in and talks him into
a deal and he has to personally use
himself as a shield in order to protect
him
Acosta similar to real life is killed
during the situation and thus he cannot
provide more intel on Felix
however Felix still has problems on top
of this not only is he betrayed by
Hector
he's also tasked with shipping 70 tons
in what seems like an almost impossible
situation he requires the government's
assistance for this and because of it
the election results become crucial his
manipulation is discovered and he
reaches out to other connected figures
in order for them to help they alter the
election results and once more Mexico
falls victim to a fraud government Felix
is back on to move the product but this
blind ambition to shift 70 tons also
puts a target on his back
he once more shows that endless ambition
can be a bad thing and Felix's downfall
was based purely on the fact that he
tried to step outside of the accepted
rules and run things his own way this
was exemplified in Kiki's death and also
his goal here just as the planes are
about to take off the operation is
brought to a halt by the DEA and it
really ramps up the stakes in the
penultimate episode turns out to be an
ambush and it makes for a gripping and
tense standoff between both sides of the
fence Walt is left as the only survivor
and put on reassignment the people he
promised rewards to for the help are
neglected and it's clear that this was a
big loss for the DEA and Sacramento he's
resigned to a desk job and has to watch
the seizures on the news it comes as a
shock to everyone when the biggest haul
ever is brought in our warehouse and
this massively rocked Felix and his
associates plans felix sends out a hit
squad and an assassin kills Hector's
wife and her children this really
happened with Felix's mole getting the
character to fall in love with him and
then he executes her however the way the
show portrays the events is different to
real life in real life Raphael convinced
Hector's wife to steal two million pesos
from him and escaped to San Francisco
together however at a hotel
Raphael cut her throat and then 15 days
later took the children out and threw
them over the bridge the real-life tale
is far more brutal
with Rafael sending a videotape of his
children's death and Guadalupe is
preserved frozen head to Hector Hector
caught up to him as we saw and it's safe
to say that things didn't go well for
him the season starts to wrap-up with
Felix bringing a new deal to the plaza
bosses that will run the Colombians out
business again people are shaken by
Felix's ambition and many step out
including our chapo Amado reveals that
they've made a deal behind his back and
he's out this leaves him with pretty
much nothing and none of the protection
he has come to have in both seasons is
about to escape out of her organization
and she continues to operate on her own
who territory is taken and she's forced
into handcuffs as mentioned earlier we
know what happens to the character but
there is potential that this may differ
in the next season Felix is finally
placed under arrest and told to keep his
mouth shut in exchange for his life it's
quite a tragic end for the character as
he was pretty much sold out by those he
helped to get where they were in
contrast it's at this time that Walt is
called back to operate in our Paso it
seems like a small victory for the
character but as we know going ahead
things will be difficult but what
happens next well Felix was charged with
the death of Kiki and the multiple
crimes he committed his jail time
exposed corruption within the Mexican
government and several police commanders
were arrested and 90 officers ended up
deserting their posts even in jail
Felix remained a big trafficker until he
was transferred to a maximum-security
prison as part of the 37 year prison
sentence Felix suffered from vertigo
deafness the loss of an eye and he was
placed in a Cell for me as by - he
requested to be transferred home upon
his 70th birthday
due to his declining health but this was
denied Walt also visits Felix in the
finale and shows him how his entire
world crumbled around him it really
feels like the perfect way to end the
run with Walt rubbing Kiki in Felix's
face the show ends with the pauses
joining forces and as we know they would
go on to form one of the biggest
narcotic empires of all time led
predominantly by Oh chapo they will end
up becoming their own cartels and
creating a bigger problem than Felix
would ever be the cage is now open and
the
world is about to see the animal set
free the show teases the rise of El
Chapo and Amato with Walt realizing that
he has to stop them no matter what it's
a brilliant way to set up the next entry
and it definitely gets you hyped for the
next season but what did I think of the
season overall well though it did start
off slow by about Episode six I was
completely on board
it's another outstanding entry in the
show and once more it cements narcos is
one of the best TV shows in recent
memory everything works here and it
feels like much more of a personal
journey than what's come before
knockos Mexico is another excellent
entry and it gets an 8.5 out of 10 now
obviously I loved hear your thoughts on
the show so comment below and let me
know make sure you subscribe to the
channel for videos like this every day
and if you want something else to watch
we've got a great breakdown of last
week's Netflix series lock and key at
the end every month in the 15th we give
away free blu-rays and all you have to
do to be in with a chance of winning dr.
sleep is leave a like and subscribe with
notifications on if you want to support
the channel and get to see content early
then please consider clicking the join
button you can also come chat to us on
our discord server link below or a
definition whitey on Twitter
thanks for magna til the end of the
video I've been definition you've been
the best not see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]